[Music]
hey everybody awesome news you may have
heard that HBO is developing a watchman
TV series so I'll try to explain what's
going on when we might see footage in
how it'll treat the comic book story
Westworld
is a good map marker for this West world
TV show from the West world movie
because this is DC Comics I'm going to
go ahead and do a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video so if you didn't know
Watchmen is now part of DC Comics in
Geoff Johns is very literally crossing
over the watch main characters with the
DC Comics Canon using the rebirth series
that's culminating in the Doomsday Clock
series in November when the Justice
League movie is getting ready to drop so
that's why this symbol here the smiley
face with the blood on it looks like
it's counting up like the Doomsday Clock
that idea is actually taken directly
from the Watchmen comic book so you've
either seen the movie or you've read the
comic book now they're turning it into
an HBO series they tried to do it a
couple years ago you might have heard
around 2014 Zack Snyder was trying to
adapt a version of his movie for HBO it
didn't end up working out he left that
project so even the new Watchmen series
might feel a lot like the movie I think
it'll take more from the comic book just
because it'll have ten episodes eight to
ten episodes of season to deal with plot
they'll probably try to get at least
five seasons out of it it's not supposed
to be a miniseries so they can just
spend more time with each of the
characters they can do bigger minutemen
flashback because if you've ever watched
the Watchmen ultimate cut movie it's
really long but they still cut a lot of
stuff out of the comic book they haven't
said whether or not it's going to pick
up where the movie picks up in the comic
book with the death of the comedian and
then you sort of flashback you learn
their story is war shack pieces together
the mystery of Ozymandias and why it is
he's doing what he's doing
so Rorschach thinks someone's hunting
The Watchmen I think it's possible
so just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen Watchmen I'll explain a
little bit of the story but during the
mid 80s Alan Moore had this idea that
people had started to give up personal
responsibility to their governments
in America was the Reagan era in the UK
it was Margaret Thatcher era but he felt
like people had turned these
governmental figures into heroes like
comic book heroes in the attitude was
they'll take care of me they have
everything in hand don't worry there's
nothing to fear so he wrote this story
who watches the Watchmen who watches out
for the heroes that are watching out for
us
and it became this big grand
deconstruction of the idea of
superheroes so the main plot is all
about Ozymandias and og Watchmen who
comes to the realization because that's
part of his ability he's just incredibly
smart he comes to the realization that
if Humanity is going to survive they
need to take back control of their own
destinies and start taking care of
themselves in not turning over that
responsibility to heroes so he goes
about killing all of the Watchmen say if
I kill them and I turn the populace
against these heroes then they'll start
to realize that they need to save
themselves but Rorschach starts piecing
together this murder mystery and he
tries to warn everyone he has this big
journal that he turns over to a
right-wing newspaper part of the reason
why HBO probably had trouble adapting
this into a series before is because
it's very pessimistic superheroes are
very popular right now look at the
Marvel movies they had the complete
opposite philosophical view from Alan
Moore's view of superheroes superheroes
are awesome they're fun they're hopeful
they're inspirational they've even taken
that turn in the DC Comics movies with
characters like Wonder Woman she's my
and Diana Princess of cinnamon Prince
Diana Prince so the ideas are just
completely counter to what a Watchmen
series would be like so it's very
different but you understand why HBO is
the place for this it can be every bit
as hardcore as the comic and if they
really wanted to they could do rehash to
the comic book the end point would
obviously be the end point of the comic
book where Ozymandias blows up Manhattan
blames dr. Manhattan so that he leaves
the earth and you get the idea that
humanity might save itself but then
there's a big twist with Rorschach's
Journal implying the people will learn
about what Ozymandias did and they look
to heroes again to save them just
starting the cycle over again there's a
lot that's been said about Zack Snyder's
treatment of the property he did a very
comic book faithful version of the movie
and even though it's a great movie I
think that at the time it wasn't
received as well as people expected
because the tone is so dark and so
pessimistic about the idea of
superheroes but I think a lot of people
went into the movie expecting a regular
superhero movie without realizing what
the Watchmen story is all about it's all
about the idea that superheroes are
ultimately bad for Humanity is actually
a very Lex Luthor concept so even if you
don't know Watchmen you know Superman
you know his relationship with Lex
Luthor the reason that Lex Luthor hates
Superman is a very watchmen twist
he thinks that everybody looks to
Superman to save them and they stop
thinking about saving themselves he
wants humanity to pull itself up by its
own bootstraps he thinks of himself as
the ultimate humanist and Superman is an
alien an alien false messiah that's come
to earth and people are now worshipping
and because of that he thinks that it's
completely halted the evolution of the
human race which i think is a very
pessimistic view and I think that he's
wrong I think people are inspired by a
Superman it's just that Lex Luthor is
very myopic vision of the situation so
it's a bit more cartoonish but Alan
Moore tried to do a very real-world
version of this like he tried to make it
feel as real as possible that's why
everyone's powers work the way they work
dr. Manhattan is really the only actual
superhero in it everyone else is just a
normal person who takes
a mantle has a specific set of skills
but if you haven't started reading d.c
rebirth yet I would recommend that you
start it's all about the idea of the
watchman versus the Justice League
so dr. Manhattan is blame for all this
pessimistic stuff that's been happening
in the DC universe in Superman is going
to fight him in November but when they
say fight him really what I think is
going to happen is that he's going to
remind dr. Manhattan of his humanity
because that's the whole idea Superman
is an alien from another planet but he's
the ultimate representation of human
potential in the idealism of humanity
dr. Manhattan is an actual human who was
turned into a god and completely lost
his humanity so it's all about these
competing philosophies and I think it'll
culminate in Superman reminding dr.
Manhattan that he still has a soul even
though he's this godlike figure with
ultimate power he's basically the most
powerful person in the DC Universe now
but let me know what you guys think
about this if everything goes well with
the serious development HBO might drop a
teaser at Comic Con next summer for like
a 2019 premiere but I don't think that
we're going to see the series before
then so when you're thinking about them
doing the series think about the way
they turned a two-hour Westworld movie
into a West World TV show they might do
the same thing with the Watchmen series
because West world turned out to be
great and we are actually getting
Westworld season 2 next year so of
course I'll do videos for the series
when it gets here but leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments there's a bunch of spider-man's
that they announced today there's also
more Game of Thrones that I'll be
posting so while you wait for everything
you can click here to rewatch the Game
of Thrones trailer and you can click
here for brand new flash thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight